brief note in just a few days i'll be
announcing the physics and consciousness
explication contest it's a contest
that's effectively the physics and
consciousness version of three blue one
brown's summer of math exposition for
people who want to create an explainer
video for some concept in physics or
consciousness it could be a theory of
everything a toe it could be an
ingredient to a toe for example what are
ashtakar variables or hofstede or
strange loop or how does quantum
entanglement speed work and wolfram's
theory brilliance has come on board to
give 1000 usd to each of the five
winners that is 5000 in total to be
distributed among the top five there's
information about this in the discord
under hashtag pace1 if you'd like to
create a video but aren't sure if your
idea fits then do ask in the discord
link is in the description or you can go
to tinyurl.com
discord t-o-e again this will be
officially announced in just a few days
on this channel
there's a slew of content in the
mathematics physics and consciousness
space that gets unduly little attention
i know what it's like to be a struggling
creator putting almost everything into
your channel without recognition from
anyone publicly for years and that's in
large part because it's a competitive
landscape but it doesn't have to be the
goal of toe that is the theories of
everything channel is not just to be a
channel or a podcast but a project and
the project is that which furthers the
explication of theories of everything
including the ingredients that go into
them thus for toe it's not a competition
but a group effort now this sundry list
has about four criteria number one
they're channels that if you enjoy the
themes of the tow channel you're likely
to enjoy them as well number two they're
on youtube number three they have
approximately 15 000 subscribers
or less sometimes even 100 and so this
way you know you're truly supporting up
and coming creators and number four
they're active so for example they have
recent publications none of the channels
mentioned here have paid me in any way
there's no sponsorship for this video
from anyone in fact these people these
channels don't even know that i'm
mentioning them so if you like any of
their videos go to one of them comment
and say that you're from the theories of
everything channel in order it will be
physics consciousness mathematics
psychology and outliers starting with
physics this channel is tobias osborne
as i said in the crash course on physics
video which i'll link in the description
as well as place a thumbnail here if
you're lucky enough to get an instructor
who writes clearly and explains each
step then you're going to learn at a
drastically faster rate tobias has that
in spades
many of his videos are in german however
you can take a look at the playlist and
you'll see he has conformal field theory
an introduction to symplectic geometry
advanced quantum field theory quantum
field theory quantum noise and
decoherence advanced quantum theory i'm
a huge fan of tobias tobias if you're
watching this thank you so much for your
channel and i appreciate how you place
so much emphasis on writing clearly and
using a 4k camera that's rare next is
professor m does science you'll see that
they have many videos on undergraduate
concepts in quantum mechanics for a
spicy take on physics both physically
and sociologically unzicker's real
physics channel is a place to go he
talks about why black holes are a
misleading concept and
variable speed of light theories his
issues with string theory his issues
with richard feynman keep in mind that
unzicker so pictured here is going to be
on the theories of everything channel
sometime this year or next year if you
have any questions for him
note them or comment them below quantum
sense only has two videos but they're
masterfully done this is chapter one in
the foundations of quantum mechanics
many people want to know what's the
minimum amount they need to know for
quantum mechanics and it's linear
algebra and if you want to be as a bit
more advanced than representation theory
but here he goes through linear algebra
i don't know where chapter two is but
that's a question for him
zap physics is another channel that i
enjoy and you can see some of the
topics here they're qft and then quantum
mechanics as well he also covers why
entropy is not about disorder which is
something that i unsuccessfully tried to
argue to thomas campbell and lee cronin
another channel that many of you may
like if you like the toe channel is
steven e robbins he's a huge proponent
of henry berkson's theories and you'll
see he covers sometimes even toe videos
as well as other people's like sabine
hostenfelder's videos and gives his
opinion from a bergson perspective he
also touches on consciousness which
brings us to our next topic
consciousness the demystifying science
podcast has many interviews that if
you're a regular of the toe channel
you'll recognize some of these people
here
so me aryan is the next channel you'll
see
she touches on consciousness psychology
and entrepreneurship she's particularly
prolific in that she puts out a video
once a week or so and i like her video
with
diana pasulka
mind body solution with dr tevin naidu
here you go there's chomsky there's
michael evan there's donald hoffman now
hey if you like this don't go switching
brown people on me there's room for both
the meaning code with karen wong again
similar themes and interviewees as the
toe channel so for example here there's
jonathan verviki and michael levin i
also appreciate how generally she
timestamps her videos
reason with science is another channel
you may enjoy and of course asking
anything an upcoming channel that just
started a few months ago with massive
ask me anythings with bernardo castro
and donald hoffman is a channel you may
want to check out of course there's
tyler goldstein that is theory of
everyone with a zero instead of an o for
everyone what makes tyler unique is that
he has his own toe his own theory of
everything and he also covers much like
steven robbins
other people's videos and gives his
points of view on them so for example
here he has his opinions on the
interviews from the tow channel with
stefan alexander or carl fristen noam
chomsky the most recent one with carl
fristin mike 11 and chris fields
this is a channel i highly recommend
that you check out the last one on the
consciousness space is mathematical
consciousness science
these ones are more lecture based which
means
it's best not listened to but watched
with a pen and paper because they're
often equations
that brings us into a smooth transition
into the mathematics side now
chalk
chalk is a channel i like because it's a
mix of mathematics but also what it's
like to study mathematics at the phd
level personally i would love to see
this is from nathan and nathan if you're
watching this i would love to see more
material from your phd another channel
is diet i can't even pronounce this
diatrix labs again all the links are in
the description what's great about this
channel is that it gets into
the equations of fairly advanced
material so for example if you're
interested in an introduction to string
theory
here is the easiest quote-unquote
problem in string theory he goes through
the complete standard model lagrangian
which almost no one writes down because
it's far too unwieldy but he goes
through and explains the terms and this
channel is by sam and personally i
prefer the videos where he's not just
reading from the powerpoint slide or his
pdf and going through because going
through the equations and writing them
out in real time is more engaging but i
highly recommend his channel anyhow he's
the only one on youtube or one of the
only ones that puts out content of this
kind
now there's cryoscience now if you've
ever wanted a gentle introduction to qft
this is it now there are different forms
of qft like algebraic axiomatic
constructive
functional integrations and expansions
vertex operator algebra approaches and
so on the way that i like to think of
cryoscience's approaches asmr qft you'll
see what i mean when you listen to a
couple of them now if you wondered about
some of the approaches i just spewed off
for the rigorous treatments of quantum
field theory then go to graduate physics
now i know this is not mathematics but
it borders on it it has recent
developments in the field sometimes i
get asked how does one stay current in a
field well by subscribing to channels
like this another mathematics channel i
enjoy is kyle broders he's a phd student
and similar to chalk you not only learn
some mathematics but also what it's like
to be a phd student
and similar to chalk i would like to see
more material from
kyle's phd soon we'll be doing a dive
into category theory and physics and so
rooney's channel is a great introduction
if you are unsure of what well deram
cohomology is or homotopic theory or
what the yonita
lemma or theorem is it's the hallmark of
category theory it's the first major
result now this one sud guy lacmo i
don't know how to pronounce that this is
a brilliant brilliant channel
this person is responsible for getting
me interested in interviewing someone
named david hestings on geometric
algebra which is another field of
mathematics that one can use in physics
as a unifying language of physics where
some of the equations of physics that
seem baroque
broken and broke are made succinct and
clear from the geometric algebraic
perspective zetamath is a channel that
i've recently come upon and you can
learn about the riemann hypothesis here
rigorously this is rare now this is just
beautiful this is from manifold in
maryland
this is a student who has wonderful
drawings look at this this is just an
explanation of what's called the lee
derivative it looks like lie but it's
pronounced li and i just found out about
this channel yesterday moving on to
psychology we have greg henrique's
unified theory of knowledge
podcast so for example i'm interviewed
here
and you'll see several others like john
verveiki are interviewed
charlotte fraza it's such a warmly
informative sedulous channel i had to
include it i just happened upon this
about a week or two ago i was looking up
the rudiments of computational
neuroscience and she has videos
dedicated to just that how do you
self-study the mathematics behind
computational neuroscience or how do you
read papers faster as a phd student next
up is the bigger picture podcast
which is also fluorescent and you'll
recognize many of the people from toe
and its ringlets
another podcast you may enjoy is called
the anagagi podcast which has interviews
with greg henriques and john verveiki
which seems to be what one does as a
default when starting a podcast you
don't have a podcast until john vervicky
has been on i know there are plenty of
people who are interested in the ufo
topic and while that's not a focus of
this channel of the tow channel is
certainly a motif and one of the
channels i highly recommend is ross
coldheart's need to know with zebel
sober analyses seasoned individuals next
is alien girl which usually comprises
commentary on recent ufo events next
there's of course that ufo podcast again
links to all of these will be in the
description they've interviewed
virtually everyone george knapp luella
sandow brandt cameron travis taylor ross
coldheart then there's the extremely
professional and cultivated and
impassioned christina gomez you can take
a look at some of the topics she has
here and a link to her channel will be
in the description i recommend you at
least check it out and then there's of
course red panda koala this is one of
the best channels on the entire list he
makes me want to weep he should be hired
by netflix he produces these great
documentaries so look here how the cia
and air force have created the ufo
stigma what are tom delong's views on
the ufos and how did he get into this
field it's astounding that this is even
free because there's content that you
pay for on other channels that isn't
even a scintilla of the quality of this
one now for some spicy takes from people
who aren't afraid of offending perhaps
they even enjoy offending just a bit i
will list three here in quick succession
because i'm running out of time there's
gaffon
there's thomas fessler
and there's truth seekers i'm shouting
them out in part because i think many
people are hesitant to even acknowledge
them lastly there are a couple channels
that don't fit nicole vanderhoven i find
it beneficial to learn how others think
regardless of whether or not those
approaches diverge from my own mode as
hearing them explain their own thought
process helped me introspectively
evaluate and critique my own manner of
thinking you can see that she puts a
tremendous amount of effort into her
videos despite having a full-time job
another channel i enjoy is joe
autohotkeyguru joeglines that is
autohotkey is a program on windows which
helps you save time by automating
monotonous tasks they even have a video
where they covered a request from kurt
from myself another small creator that i
enjoy is sigma documentaries they put
plenty of effort into their videos and
it's staggering how small their
subscriber count is they have
documentaries on bacteria that eats
plastic on fractals in nature on
piezoelectric materials it's just
staggering the last miscellaneous
channel is thin reaper again all of
these are in the description i happen to
like video game essays i generally fall
asleep to them and i enjoy the work of
this creator and hopefully you will as
well alright that's it visit the
creators in the description and see if
they're your cup of tea make sure to let
them know that you came from the
theories of everything channel so
comment that hey this is from kurt's
recommendation from toe or however you
want to phrase it it will brighten their
day will brighten mine to see some
comments like that on these underrated
channels thank you if you want to
support the tow channel the theories of
everything project then go to
patreon.comgymongo that is c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n
your support helps every dollar helps
tremendously you may not think it does
but it helps it helps an extreme amount
every time i get a patron it goes on my
phone and i show my wife the
notification and she's super
appreciative as well she's oh my gosh
that's so kind babe so my wife and i
both thank you thank you so much click
on some of the channels in the
description and visit these underrated
underappreciated creators take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
[Music]
you